well this morning we have two special
guests uh and we're going to talk about
french the french language and in
particular street french and to talk
about street french i have here maya and
charlie from paris and they have a
youtube channel which teaches people how
to speak street french so perhaps i
could ask you to introduce yourselves
teddy hi my name is charlie and i'm maya
and i'm french and i'm american and we
both live in paris right
and yeah and we started street french
um
because of you right yeah yeah it's kind
of like my story about how i learned
french in school and how i wasn't very
effective in real life situations
and i got really into learning like
slang and just like that really casual
way that a lot of people speak in
everyday life
now for me of course that's uh
backwards because i i'm not very good at
street french
because but i'm the same as you in the
sense that i didn't really learn it at
school but i learned it when i got
interested in french civilization for
its culture and i studied in france for
three years but and i should say that
after this video we're going to do
another one for their channel where
they're going to challenge my knowledge
of street french and slang and i will do
very poorly
but so tell me
uh is it that you want people to learn
the slang or is it that the so many
people are interested in slang that that
kind of brings them to the language um
it's a little bit of both a lot of our
clients they come to either study in
france or they come here for work and
they find that they're not very
effective at speaking the language
because they only learn textbook french
and they find that people speak very
differently in real life
right yeah i guess it's not only
focusing on on slang words but it's more
right the spoken language that is pretty
different from literature and everything
you find in textbooks
so what are your techniques how do you
help people acquire this spoken language
um something that we tell people that's
probably the most important thing is to
speak with someone you have to have a
friend at least one person that you
could practice with
fairly regularly and i find people are
really just stuck in textbooks and
they're you know trying to do their
homework and they don't practice
actually using the language and so it
makes sense that they're not very good
at it when they try to hold a
conversation yeah usually they think
they can learn a lot of things and then
just like okay i'm gonna start talking
now and it's gonna work out on its own
you know but it's something you need to
practice too
so
a couple of questions first of all if
someone lives in boston or buffalo new
york how do they find someone to talk to
oh the interesting the interesting thing
about that is i used to live in la
that's where i'm from and i found a
group on meetup.com
and it was a group of people learning
french they were all most of them were
americans or they weren't like native
speakers but they knew more than me and
just going there every week for like two
years really helped me a lot it helped
me learn how to converse
[Music]
you know that's that's very interesting
because i mean we have meetups here in
vancouver as well in different languages
japanese korean chinese friends probably
and they also have this mundo lingo have
you heard of them
no
and there's also the polyglot group in
paris i mean there are groups that one
can find on the internet where you can
get together with people that it's
either language exchange or things of
that nature
okay so meetup.com what other bits of
advice do you provide to people like to
find someone to practice with
well or no you said okay first of all
find someone to practice with regularly
meetup.com i should say is only just one
example of that yeah uh you could also
find someone like to skype with there
are different websites where like
conversationexchange.com i think that's
what it's called i work with someone
who's you know she's a grandmother she's
retired she's at home and she has like
four or five friends in france that she
met on that site conversation exchange
and they just chat on skype you know
regularly and i just saw her i mean
she's made like a lot of improvements in
about a year she's uh she's pretty
conversational now it's it's incredible
yeah
so so are there uh sort of particular
sort of phrases or you know aspects of
the language that you teach or stress in
your videos yeah actually we
let's say like the ebooks
you wrote and we worked on together we
kind of uh leave out some parts of the
french language that we don't use in
spoken french like for example some
tenses like passes sound or things like
that that you're never ever going to
hear a french person he used in spoken
french in with friends or even in formal
situations it's like in french you have
like spoken french then you have formal
like to be polite and then you have like
super high level formal that's like way
too much
yeah and that's what we try to like
avoid and and i see yeah like one
example
a lot of times people say
like when they want to ask what
something means
and right the average french person is
probably not going to say like that
they'll say come on dia
um
right yeah and so we okay we show them
differences like that um
asking questions yeah and yeah so so uh
in your typical video then you would
take some examples and then show how
they're used
is that how it's done uh sometimes i
mean we we do all kinds of videos
sometimes we just have a conversation or
we just discuss like a different topic
um or we have one video where we talk
about why you shouldn't use inversions
in in conversation i mean if you want to
it's just that
most french people don't use inversions
when they speak in everyday life
yeah we either give tips like that or we
try to make
videos and lessons and actually our
private lessons we do that like that too
we start from the conversation and we
make it a lesson so okay i want to say
this or let's say you watch a video and
they said certain things why did they
say like that we always like focus on
that like um yeah yeah i react to some
celebrities speaking french oh they said
that that's interesting or they could
have said this better like more natural
etc naturally
so
are your videos then essentially all in
french
i know a lot of them are english some of
them are lessons some of them are in
french some of them are you know maya
reacting to a french selector to a
celebrity speaking french yeah
okay so those those that are in french
do they do you provide transcripts or
subtitles
uh the the ones that are in french
yes um some some of our vlogs have
subtitles some of them don't yeah we
would like to have more but
uh
it's a lot of work yeah
we'll try to hire someone who can who
can do the transcript for us to
have more people in the team
yeah
yeah i know i mean my experience in
france was that you know i went over to
france in the 60s and i studied there
for three years
and but i agree with you textbooks
textbooks are hopeless because the the
the text
the writers of the textbook think that
they can teach you a certain structure
with this you know lesson this text and
of course we gradually pick up these
different structures we don't
necessarily learn something because it
was included in this particular lesson
right so i'm a great believer
i i certainly agree with you that you
have to speak a lot
uh and you pick up a lot when you're
speaking with people because you hear
how they're speaking uh but i i'm also
as you may know if you've seen my videos
i'm a great believer in lots of input
lots of listening and reading but it has
to be
uh things of interest and and you're
quite right you have to notice or
perhaps someone has to point out to you
that in the written language they use
the passage sample which isn't used in
the spoken language so uh but i uh i i
agree with you you have to you have to
get out there and use it but in order to
use it you have to have a
certain amount of vocabulary you can't
just start from ground zero
otherwise you can't understand what
people are saying you can't say anything
so i think it's a combination at least
in my approach a combination of lots of
listening and reading and then and now
do people that come to you like are some
of them sort of intimidated about
speaking afraid to speak and if so how
do you deal with that what advice do you
give them well i tell them to try to
envision the conversation before it
happens right like i tell someone okay
you're gonna go to a meet-up you're
gonna get past hello then you're gonna
you know you ask them how their name
this is or how you know you ask them
what their name is this is how you do it
after that you'll probably say
[Music]
can we use two with each other right
right and then right after that okay
maybe you'll ask them if they had a good
day
or if they had a good what a good
weekend and then after that you know
it's only natural that they ask you so
prepare you know something to respond to
that and it's um it's just a lot of
practice and then maybe
it might not go perfectly well the first
time but it was practice and the next
time i go better and that kind of thing
i guess it also helps them that it can
go back and forth between like going out
having real conversation and having like
a feedback or you know like uh how do
you say like a check or you know like a
sum up like in a lesson like okay i
couldn't say this or they can really
analyze what they they don't feel alone
that's basically who provides that an
analysis you you provide yeah yeah like
the private lessons we do
oh i see so you offer private lessons
uh where they can
talk about some of the problems they had
things they weren't able to express or
didn't understand well our lessons are
really focused on conversation right
we'll have a person speak about whatever
they're into or for some sometimes
someone wants to practice like a job
interview
or
if they you know they're just coming to
like travel around france for a bit okay
this is what you need to order in a
restaurant this is what you need to ask
where the restrooms are and that sort of
thing it's really a custom lesson
everyone is different
right
okay and so where are most of your
customers located
uh really all over the world we have um
we have skype lessons and we have
students everywhere um yeah probably
mostly the us australia yeah i guess our
audience on youtube is mostly from the
us on instagram there's a lot of people
who are from iran or
or india or like there's people all over
the world really
okay now another question
french as a language i mean it used to
be the diplomatic language it was it had
a very high level of prestige and and
recently you know it seems like the
whole world is learning english and then
you get a
people who want to learn chinese or
japanese and
what's the appeal of french why do
people want to learn french i mean i
love french
but i'm just wondering what what is the
status of french in terms of its level
of popularity and the reasons why people
learn it today interesting i think it's
really personal what we saw in everyone
we met they all had
either like they wanted to get in touch
with their
origins you know like they had family
centuries ago in france and they wanted
to explore that others wanted to come to
france to work because i don't know one
was from from greece and really feels
attached to the european uh
culture i guess she worked in germany
but she didn't really like it there she
preferred the
french i don't know the french culture i
guess it really is so personal
from person to person yeah if you even
had some like doctors and nurses on
their way to africa to work with like uh
doctors without borders they'll take a
couple lessons with us
before they start their humanitarian
work down there
okay yeah there's not like one appeal
for everyone like chinese oh it's it
could be good for business or english
too but french is more like i don't know
it's more precious it's more personal i
feel like
yeah yeah oh it's a lovely language and
i mean personally i was attracted uh in
the 60s by you know
the culture the nouvelle vag the films
and stuff and i i lived there in the 60s
it was magic i was in ghana for one year
and then two years in paris i had a
bicycle i had the chamber bun uh you
know and my bicycle dove to sean's po
every day
crossing la place de la concorde on my
bicycle dodging uh
cars
it was already crazy
back then
because it's still oh yeah
once you reach that level of crazy you
can't get crazier so you've got
the car on the inside trying to get to
the outside
you know and i'm there in between hoping
to survive every morning exactly but uh
no i loved it i loved it absolutely oh
that's great i think it's great that
you're promoting french
uh i think it's great that you're
i think people have to kind of get a
sense of how people use the language and
you're quite right very often the books
don't provide that movies don't even
provide that i find sometimes the
dialogue in movies or and that's in any
language the sitcoms whatever it's a
little it's artificial
so it's not really how people use the
language so yeah if you can help people
you know sound like they're natural
which and here's another question
to speak to use the language the way
people use it makes the native speaker
feel more comfortable
exactly uh but it doesn't require a
perfect accent yeah in my experience
yeah definitely i think people are far
too obsessed with accent whereas really
it's it's the word choice and and how
they express themselves that matter yeah
is that do you find that your customers
or your your people you deal with
are a little obsessed with accent or not
necessarily some of them can feel very
self-conscious about their accent and i
keep telling them that it's fine i mean
we all know someone who speaks english
or like their native language with an
accent but we can understand them more
or less fine right and it's just really
about putting yourself out there and and
just trying
exactly and and not only i mean i've
dealt with so many
non-native speakers of english in
business and
it's not that just that we don't mind
their accent
when we hear someone use the language
well with an accent i'm always impressed
at how well they use the language the
the accent is almost irrelevant if i
find someone who's you know i steve
slaps me on the back and thinks he's
being very you know canadian or
something but he can't speak very well
i'm not very impressed
so uh yeah
right
it's exactly it becomes a caricature
character okay well we will leave uh
details to your youtube channel and any
other relevant information in the
description box uh it's always good to
connect up with uh language
entrepreneurs who are promoting the
learning of different languages and now
for your channel we're gonna you're
gonna quiz me on my knowledge of slang
and i think i'm gonna do very poorly but
i never
worry about putting myself out there as
you said that's great thank you very
much thank you so much
[Music]
you